there's a really interesting story going
on with Fox News host Laura Ingraham
that I want to spend a little time
talking about with you today a Laura
Ingraham you might remember was brought
into Fox News as a host sort of during
and throughout the shake-up involving a
number of hosts she was a fill-in for a
while off and on for Bill O'Reilly who
eventually left Fox in total shame after
multiple sexual assault allegations and
settlements other hosts came in and out
and eventually she got herself a show
called the Ingraham angle and she's
horrible like truly truly horrible she's
known for when she was in high school
she wrote a letter to the parent of some
classmate outing them as gay because she
didn't like that and found out that they
were involved in some group on campus I
don't even remember the story maybe
she's apologized maybe she hasn't but
she's got a lot of really horrible stuff
in her past and most recently she's
gotten into trouble because she
criticized victims of the parkland
Florida mass school shooting and a lot
of people didn't like it and
specifically David hog who's one of the
students who's been more publicly seen
as an activist around gun safety after
the shooting she tweeted or he tweeted
rather that he had been rejected from
four universities and that Ingram
accused him of whining about it and
Laura Ingram's tweet about this was
David hog rejected by four colleges to
which he applied and whines about it
dinged by UCLA with a 4.1 GPA totally
predictable given acceptance rates now
it might not seem like that big of a
deal but this is a powerful corporate
media host who's going on Twitter and
making fun of a kid who didn't get into
college as a kid who has made himself
publicly known after the parkland
Florida shooting and David hog tweeted
back calling for a boycott of Laura
Ingram's advertisers saying so Ingraham
angle Laura Ingraham what are your
biggest advertisers asking for a friend
hashtag boycotting boycotting Gramm
adverts and this got a lot of people to
start calling for boycotts of the long
list of companies that advertise or
advertised past-tense
on Laura Ingraham show and many of those
companies have announced
we're not gonna advertise with laura
ingraham anymore and the companies
include Home Depot Hulu TripAdvisor
Expedia Johnson & Johnson Liberty Mutual
Liberty Mutual I am a customer of I
tweeted to them saying pull your ads
from Laura Ingraham and then of course
after nearly a dozen advertisers or more
said were not advertising with her
anymore she put out an apology
clearly completely out of necessity due
to the disastrous press around the time
where she said any student should be
proud of a 4.2 GPA including david hog
on reflection in the spirit of holy week
pandering to the religious people I
apologize for any upset or hurt my tweet
caused him or any of the brave victims
of parkland for the record I believe my
show was the first to feature David and
then she goes on to just try to pander
and now lo and behold Laura Ingraham is
on a week vacation the speculation is
that this was not a planned vacation
just like when Bill O'Reilly was sent on
a vacation when advertisers started
bailing before he was pulled out here's
Laura Ingraham announcing this I'll be
off next week for Easter break with my
kids but fear not we've got a great
lineup of guest hosts to fill in for me
yeah so the obvious question is was it a
planned vacation or is this a forced
vacation she didn't mention it before is
this the beginning of a Bill O'Reilly
type firing so listen I would love to
see her lose her show because it's a
terrible show and it spreads
disinformation the real issue I want to
talk about is that as soon as I tweeted
to Liberty Mutual saying please drop
Laura Ingraham and ultimately Liberty
Mutual did lot drop Laura Ingraham
people started tweeting to me saying
David don't you defend free speech
shouldn't Laura Ingraham be allowed to
say whatever it is that she wants why is
she being persecuted and punished for
what she said and of course this is a
very common misunderstanding of free
speech Laura Ingraham is free to say
whatever she wants wherever she wants to
say it provided that her employer Fox
News says that she can say whatever she
wants on air and it seems they hired her
to be controversial and she can tweet
whatever the hell she wants but free
speech doesn't mean that there can be no
consequences to that speech Ingraham has
free speech rights to say what she wants
every single FoxNews viewer Twitter user
can react to that speech by
saying I like it or I don't like it or
I'm going to lobby her advertisers to
stop advertising on her show that is
them utilizing their free speech
now then people could come to me and say
but David someone could unfairly target
the david pakman show Zaid vert eyes
errs including your new ones like shaker
and spoon and brilliant whoever else and
my answer would be that's right they
could I can say whatever I want my
viewers can say whatever they want to my
advertisers and my advertisers can also
use whatever information is important to
them to say we are or aren't going to
advertise on the David Pakman show that
is how it works
no one's free speech is being violated
no one is being censored there's no
government or law enforcement
intervention in anyone's speech
whatsoever everybody gets to say what
they want sort of direct incitement to
violence which is my view on free speech
and everyone gets to make the personal
decisions the business decisions about
what they watch where their company
advertises I could be hurt by the same
tactics that are hurting Laura Ingraham
but I can't be a hypocrite no one is
doing anything wrong so what is there
for me to be against now should Fox News
fire her listen Fox News hired her
knowing that she had all sorts of
horrible statements in her past my
instinct is that they're not gonna fire
her for what she said but if the show no
longer makes money because Fox is a
for-profit company then all of a sudden
they might say well this is no longer of
use to us and she's gonna have to go
they may keep her around too because the
turnover there is already so high I mean
we can't afford to lose another Fox host
sure we've already lost Bill O'Reilly
and Yahoo Carlson and megyn kelly
let's goes on and on sure yeah I mean
maybe as a staffing thing they might
keep her but in in terms of the
arguments around free speech and
censorship and all of this other stuff
come on I am no hypocrite I have the
exact same standard for her as I do for
me and I would have to deal with the
consequences if I said something really
offensive and people lobbied my
advertisers to drop the show the video
you just watched was made possible by
support from you please go to
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
can make a pledge of as little as $1 per
month and every dollar helps to support
the work that we're doing particularly
in light of the YouTube ad boycott which
has been
really bad